what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones
prediction video today I want to talk
about our favourite Kingslayer Sir Jaime
[ __ ] Lannister Jaime is one of those
characters that most people either love
or hate but regardless of how you feel
about him he may be faced with arguably
the toughest decision of his life which
will affect all of Westeros which makes
Jaime Lannister a very important
character in terms of the end game Jaime
is definitely a conflicted character at
heart
which kind of takes us as fans on a
rollercoaster ride of emotions when it
comes to this character he is always
walking that fine line between good and
evil and although he has done some
pretty foul [ __ ] I still like this
character but if you hate him and want
him dead then I completely understand
that I will not dispute that because
there was a time when I also hated Jaime
Lannister but I think there is still
light at the end of the tunnel for him
and I believe he will do what's right in
the end and he will end up with some
good deeds written down in that white
book one of my very first videos I made
was about the Lannisters and in that
video I basically made a prediction
saying that when and if Jaime dies I
think Brienne will make sure that Jaime
has his pages filled up with the good
deeds that he has done and there might
not be that many things to say yet but
in due time there will be in my opinion
so let's get into this then what will
Jaime Lannister's endgame be what will
be his final act whether good or bad and
feel free to comment below with your
predictions because I'd love to hear
them but let's first discuss arguably
the most popular theory out there which
is the valonqar theory this is going to
be for the show only because I think the
valonqar will be a different person in
the books gray area had made a great
video about the valonqar theory and in
my opinion I think she got it right but
like I said I think it's going to be
different in the show the majority of
the game of Thrones community believes
that Jaime Lannister will be the one to
kill his sister and lover Cersei
Lannister the season 7 trailer even
hinted at this in a big way when Jaime
and Cersei were standing on the map you
can see Cersei is standing on the neck
and Jaime is standing near the fingers
this set off red flags across the
community because this seems to be very
clear what they are trying to say here
but this could also just be a tease but
regardless of how you want to interpret
this I think it's safe to say that
people believe Jamie will be the one to
wrap his hands around her pale white
throat and choke the life from her
obviously Jamie no longer has two hands
but that doesn't mean he still can't
choke a [ __ ] like Wayne Brady but not
only do people believe Jamie will kill
Cersei people also believe that he will
also kill himself
right afterwards that way Jamie can die
in the arms of the woman that he loves
just like he said he wanted to do and
I'm going to be honest with you that is
a very solid theory Jamie killing Cersei
then killing himself is plausible but
after thinking about this off and on
over the past few months I'm not so sure
that's the right theory I do think the
chances of Jamie killing Cersei are very
high but I'm not so sure he's going to
commit suicide right afterwards
I don't think Jamie's story is going to
end that way but in order for me to tell
you where I think his story ends we have
to go back all the way to the very
beginning of this story and that is when
Jaime Lannister shoves bran stark out
the window of the tower and Winterfell
what I think set this story in motion
was the death of Jon Arryn but when
Jamie pushed bran out of that window
that was a pivotal part of the story
that also caused the war between the
Starks and the Lannisters this was the
beginning of Jamie's story arc of being
this evil potential child murdering
incestuous loving son of a [ __ ] but
once Jamie get away from Cersei he
started to change and Brienne played a
big factor in that she basically became
his sort of motivator to do what's right
and I think in the end he will do what's
right again in my opinion I think in
order for him to fully complete his
story arc he needs to do something for
the Starks and possibly even bran stark
himself
Jamie's story was really set in motion
when he pushed bran out the window and I
think it's going to end with him doing
something right or good for the Starks
and another reason why I think this
could happen is because of something
Jamie once said that I did reference
earlier Jamie said he wanted to die in
the arms of the woman he loves do you
think Jamie is still going to love
Cersei in the end will Cersei be the
woman whose arms he dies in I'm not so
sure about that
and I know people hate the thought of
this but I think it's more likely to be
brewing in whose arms he dies in if it
does in fact to go down that way
Brienne is obviously on Team Stark right
now she has sworn to
protects onto Stark so if Jaime would
die in the arms of Brienne it could
possibly be because he sacrificed
himself for one of the Starks to live I
could easily be wrong about this but I
don't see Jaime dying by suicide you
could also say that it would be fitting
for Jamie's story to end after he saves
King's Landing again but this time
everyone would know that he did it for
the right reasons not just because he's
some king or queen Slayer he's actually
the savior of a city in all of its
citizens but I feel like he still has a
role to play after that I think Jaime
will help in the war to come against the
night king and if he dies it will be
because he did it saving one of the
Starks or maybe even Jon Snow there is
going to come a point to where Jaime has
to decide is he going to stand beside
Cersei and sink with that ship or will
he make the right decision and leave
King's Landing Cersei will eventually
lose to Daenerys and I don't see Cersei
giving up she's going to die trying
and I don't see Jaime going out like
that he's either gonna kill Cersei
before she goes mad again or he's going
to abandon her either way Jaime will
eventually leave King's Landing which he
will then side with Tyrion or Brienne
Tyrion and bran
both have a stark connection which could
also put Jaime in position to do the
right thing by the Starks but these are
all just my opinions and I would
completely understand if you disagree
with me so comment below and tell me
what you think Jaime's end games going
to be do you agree with me or do you see
it playing out another way let me know
your thoughts as always thank you all so
much for stopping by to watch the video
and a special thanks to my supporters on
patreon I love all y'all and I'll see
you down below bye